this is the story of what it's really
like to experience War Through The Eyes
of a child
their first-hand account of what war is
like for them in Ukraine
[Music]
when I hear playing
how it felt to Run for Cover as the
world around them changed overnight
I bring all of my toys into basement and
I played with them I was just feeling
really sick
and was it from all the stress of what
was going on around you yeah I think I
was like a bit too nervous
how the children who came to the UK to
be safe still have a lot to deal with
like having to find a new place to live
Daniel are you sad about having to leave
your host family yes because we have big
place we have we are very close to my
school
and how this Refugee risks going back to
a war zone
just to hug her parents she left behind
I'm so far away and then I really really
wanted to help them it's just not
possible like you can't do anything
[Music]
FYI investigates Ukraine's children of
War
[Music]
foreign
was falling was like literally meter
from our house
[Music]
I was just feeling really sick
I had tummy ache and was it from all the
stress of what was going on around you
yeah I think I was like a bit too
nervous
we were just lying down on the floor
or on the beds so you had to lie down to
protect yourself yes
February 24th 2022 is the day the lives
of millions of Ukrainian children like
David changed forever
Russia's President Putin ordered an
invasion of Ukraine
the town of butcher near the capitol
Kiev was hit by missiles day after day
[Music]
all David and his family could do was
hide they remained in the basement of
their home for three weeks they took
photos and filmed as Russian troops
moved into their town
the house was just fine I don't know why
every house was formed
shops of course but our house was
literally fine
I I bring all of my toys into basement
and I played with them
after one week they blowed up the
electricity when we didn't have
electricity when we just had like
torches so it was completely dark in the
basement yeah
[Music]
I did feel a bit too nervous to go
outside because there were Russians on
the street and when we were in the
basement we had a lot of Russian tanks
passing literally there was like
thousands of them
Russian troops eventually agreed to an
evacuation of civilians from butcher
a Ukraine was beating Russia more so we
could go out we were a bit now protected
my mom friends meet us with a car
as they fled butcher they put a sign on
the car saying children in the hope it
would keep them safe from Russian troops
[Music]
and then we fly away with my mum to
Poland and then we
fly to England
David was clearly happy when he finally
reached the UK
they are now safe living in England with
family who have always lived here with
their experiences behind them they were
happy to share their story
[Music]
so you enjoy school here yes yeah
can you show me your classroom down down
there okay
uh I was like nervous when I the first
time got to a school but everyone was
like nice to me
more than five million Ukrainian
refugees now live across Europe 130
000 settles here in the UK half of them
are children and teenagers
most escaped from Ukraine at the start
of the invasion by traveling to
neighboring countries mainly to the
safety of Medica in Poland
[Music]
and this is where I witnessed what war
can do to innocent people for the first
time
get away from them I was reporting for
FYI as refugees poured over the border
into Poland
the first thing I noticed was that it
was mainly women and children
[Music]
families had been torn apart all men
were ordered to stay behind to take part
in the war and there were also children
who arrived without either of their
parents
it was here I met Elia her parents had
stayed behind to take care of relatives
our ninth floor was destroyed and that
was the moment when I realized that I
got to go and I just couldn't leave my
parents alone but I had no other choice
so what was it like having to leave your
parents behind I'm terrified of the
thought that someday I will call them
and they will not respond
[Music]
Alia was close to finishing her studies
and hoped to go to university in the UK
because of all of this happened in my
dreams are just crushed they are just
destroyed
one year on and I've never stopped
thinking about Elia it's a pretty big
we're about to meet again
this time in the UK
how are you I'm good your hair looks so
nice she was taken in by one of
thousands of British families who
volunteered to host refugees in their
home it's so much different in my and
her dream of studying here is now a
reality
Ellie is a student at the University
this is your room here um yeah it's
kind of in the middle
near to the show oh it's so pretty
it's so pretty do you like painting uh
yeah paint that's my recent one oh
that's so cool yeah I haven't finished
it yet I love it
yeah oh wow that's the motherland statue
in Ukraine what does that say uh glory
to Ukraine
Elia is from hawkeyev
this is what her City looks like now
devastated by Russian missile attacks
her parents fled to the capital Kiev
where it was safer
there are refugees within their own
country when you see news reports you
must worry about them so much yeah of
course you know there is like a very
popular syndrome like amongst people who
fled the war that they feel guilty for
being safe I'm so far away and even if I
really really wanted to help them it's
just not possible like you can't do
anything
I'm finding the problem for all refugees
is that no one knows how long the war
will last
I've read that an increasing number of
British families are now pulling out of
Hosting refugees some are struggling to
share their homes others are finding it
too expensive
[Music]
charity video shows Daniel a refugee
handing in a petition to the prime
minister
about
1043 okay I will let the Prime Minister
help you it is signed by 10 000 hosts
looking after 5 000 refugees asking for
more financial support
I tracked down Daniel and his mum Tanya
in High Wycombe their host family has
asked them to leave
[Music]
with fewer families offering to be hosts
they've turned to estate agents to help
them find a flat to rent hello yeah
Tanya has managed to get a job working
for a charity but money is tight
so are you looking for a two-bedroom are
you looking for a three bedroom do you
want to be in a town center it would be
really nice to to be close to Danielle's
school okay
um so the maximum that we can spend on a
property would be for yourself is a
thousand pound yeah so that's the
maximum that we could possibly
um go up to based on your income so we
came and that won't be enough for a
three-bedroomed flat for Daniel his mum
and grandmother
Daniel are you sad about having to leave
your house family yes because uh we have
big plays we have we are very close to
my school and that is very good so
um what's your options like you've been
welcomed by such a amazing family but I
can imagine for anyone it'd be difficult
having you know other people living in
your house for such a long time yeah
yeah you know we all were hoping that
all right maybe a few more months that's
10 months I think you you will agree
that it's a huge amount of time to get a
stranger into your home what what can
you afford right now would be really
nice if we could be together yeah
have a three-bedroom it's really a
challenge
shortly after Daniel handed in the
petition the government announced it
will increase the monthly payment it
gives to host families the hope is to
convince more people to welcome
Ukrainian refugees into their homes
foreign
this is my mom
and that's me and my dad
and three of us
I really miss them I haven't seen them
for a long time
I'm beginning to get a sense that
understandably most refugees just want
to go home but it just isn't a safe
option as the one year anniversary of
the Russian invasion draws an error the
capital Kiev is being bombed for the
first time in months elia's parents are
now among Millions experiencing power
Cuts in extremely cold weather
the second attack in just two days
another wave of missiles from Moscow
but life in England without her parents
is proving too much for Elia despite the
risks she's decided to head to Ukraine
to see them I don't think anything can
change my decision to go back now
[Music]
I'm very determined to see my parents
because I really need that and I feel
that seeing my parents would be a very
important moment for me to keep me going
foreign
me
all of the people who are waiting for me
there they just keep saying that it's
gonna be fine and it calms me down a bit
we're going to keep in touch with Elia
throughout her stay and the highly
experienced team are filming her return
to Ukraine
it feels so weird that I escaped this
place once and I escaped the war once
and now I'm going back there
deliberately
[Music]
after a 40-hour journey on coaches Elia
is just moments away from being with her
parents
[Music]
after a few days I wanted to see how
Elia was getting on in Ukraine
hi can you hear me hi Alia it's great to
see you I've not seen you in so long so
how are you feeling about everything
um it was very hard to see the
infrastructure being damaged and
especially realizing that your parents
and your family have been there during
these terrible things happening and you
were away you were safe while these
people the people that you care about so
much they were seeing all of this with
their own eyes they were experiencing
all of this explosion and loud sounds
and all of this air raid sirens and
stuff
which is really hard for every Ukrainian
kid right now
Elia and I want to know more about how
the war has affected other kids those
who stayed behind
we've arranged a visit to a specialist
center that Comforts children
at first this just looks like a typical
classroom
but everyone here has a shocking story
to tell
some of these children escape from towns
taken over by Russian soldiers they've
lost relatives and they've been forced
to flee from their homes
[Music]
some are so affected by a year of war
that everyday sounds can remind them of
what they witnessed
at least I'm not scared of a helicopter
I'm scared of a fighter jet because one
flew right above my head those kind of
sounds are not good to hear
others have fathers biting on the front
line
I didn't know where he was
I was calling in texting him
but mum said it's forbidden so I tried
not to
[Music]
it's hard when he calls you and you ask
how are you
how is everyone
all these children are getting
Specialist Care to help them cope with
their experiences
goodness
and today they're getting a visit from a
very special therapist
s
the pit bull terrier called Beacher
[Music]
dogs help reduce stress and anxiety
when the dog is playing with you he can
give her commands and I really like it
it's great to have some entertainment
like that
you're getting better in some way
[Music]
s
according to the children's charity
UNICEF every one of Ukraine's 5.7
million children have suffered trauma
because of the war
2.2 million have been forced to flee
their homes and over half have no school
to go to
[Music]
Alia and her parents have decided to
deal with their own experiences and
travel to harkiv
they want to see what their home City
looks like now
[Music]
there was a lot of discussion between me
and my parents who wanted to take me
back to my home City hurricane but I can
only imagine how it's gonna make me feel
when I'm gonna see the place where I
grew up being destroyed but at the same
time it might be very important to
reevaluate some things in my head
foreign
district is kind of on the edge of the
city
and it's the closest to Russian border
so it was under shelling a lot much more
than any other district and it touched
lots of things that are precious to me
as well
their apartment block has been badly
damaged
but that's not all
[Music]
just a few meters away from her home
there is a place that means so much to
Elia
foreign
[Music]
this was my English class
thankfully the school was empty when it
was bombed
this is my destroyed School
there is no place that I can come back
to and meet my teachers and my school
friends
that was my English class there
it's just very painful to see all of
this
Russians just came and took my school
years away from me
foreign
's parents have decided to move back to
their damaged apartment here in harkiv
and take care of elderly relatives
even though there is no electricity or
running water and the city is still
attacked they no longer feel the capital
Kiev where they fled to is any safer
Elia will return to the UK to focus on
her future there
like so many refugees I've met
she is determined to never give up on
her dreams and hopes for peace
to leave your family knowing that you're
gonna go to a safe place and they just
have nowhere to go
I think that's even worse than
experiencing all of these attacks and
missile strikes and shelling again
because I know that I can escape but my
loved ones cannot
[Music]
being back in hierarchive and seeing all
the destruction it was heartbreaking
[Music]
but the most important thing is that
Putin cannot destroy our dreams and stop
us from getting education
[Music]
he will never break our spirit because
our freedom and love to each other is
now stronger than ever
[Music]
we will never let Putin destroy our
future
[Music]
foreign